[Music]
what up homies what up 33% how you
living hang on say that again I am NOT
here today I'm actually flying back from
LA you're listening to this on Tuesday
were really whenever time is irrelevant
it's the internet but I'm recording an
intro just so that you know that we're
gonna get to some things later in the
week coming up in a little bit like a
minute is Ross Tucker he talks about how
competitive Tom Brady was when he was
snapping the ball Tim he talks about
sounds he talks about Drew Bledsoe it's
very funny he talks about the four
conversations that he had with Bill
Belichick during the year plus that he
was there and we even go into what's it
like to be an Eagles fan and then the
next year you're playing for the Cowboys
all good stuff that's coming up in a
second on Thursday we are gonna get to
the best competitors and the winner of
the eat like a homie 33 day challenge I
have all of your stuff all of your media
I'm gonna go over it and see who did the
best who has the best story and we'll
figure out how to work this out with
travell gains and we will recap the best
pool dunk quarterback rankings
and see who earned the number one spot
but now it is time for my conversation
with podcast magnate and former NFL
offensive lineman Ross Tucker enjoy
homies
[Music]
all right let me do one final check and
Ross Tucker according to my Twitter
account you have a hundred and
ninety-nine point nine thousand dollars
and it is [ __ ] killing me because you
walked in you're like I think I have two
hundred I was like dude I've been
checking it how long have you been at
one ninety-nine point nine I don't know
how long I've been one ninety-nine point
nine but I've been at $1.99 for a while
but you know what's weird I owe one
ninety nine nine two six Wow is what it
says what's crazy about though is on my
laptop
it says two hundred look on my laptop it
rounds up yeah but it doesn't round up
on on on my phone my forces 189,000 so
one of my main questions was like I you
probably passed so many milestones first
time you get to ten thousand first time
you got to yeah but each time are you
like because I know like when I was at
like twenty nine point nine thousand I
was like get the [ __ ] thirty let's do
this yeah you know what I mean I just
feel like this this sounds bad but like
there's a lot of people in the hundreds
like you get to two hundred thousand
there's a lot of you look and it's like
they got 128 thousand her 142,000 yeah
you get over two hundred thousand it's
like pretty good yeah and I don't think
I mean I'd never bought any I know
people can but I've never bought any I
don't bought any because I just buy any
because I just don't wanna get found out
like I don't want like Darren Revell to
do a piece that's like one of the most
fake accounts is Adam left look but I
will say this a couple times my count
has dropped when they've like cleaned
out the bots or whatever but I never I
never paid for Matt anyway we're all
stuck a huge bot guy happy to have you
in you have me on your podcast glad for
you to be here this is making me feel
very bad by the way
porque so my podcast like you just put a
headset on and somebody like calls in
and it's just audio like you're in this
unbelievable office and then we're in
this room we've got cameras everywhere
looking at me like you are you how many
pop you're making me feel bad about
myself
[ __ ] cuz how many podcasts do you do
a week
a bunch yeah sucker football podcast
fantasy feast even monies for gambling
the cows draft podcast but the thing is
Ross like a football podcast three times
a weekend during the season I do that
Bailey so you have like I don't wanna
see nine a week yeah so for me what I
realized is cuz a lot of what my
offseason show has been is more
interview based yes I can't do
interviews over the phone
it's just I'm an interrupter and like so
on the phone that makes it hard and
since I'm only doing two right now in
the off season it's like let me do more
in-person real stuff it's so much better
but once the season starts it's nuts
because it we're all trying to keep up
with that constant flow of game and then
a Thursday game than a Monday game and
then the storylines change well you know
what's funny is if I had to do it over
again so I finished playing in 2008 I
retired and I was writing for Sports
Illustrated and ESPN hired me away to
write for them and they said you want to
host our podcast I was like yeah
literally had no idea what a podcast was
I don't even have an iPhone I mean I I
know it when I pop I suppose but I knew
they were gonna pay me to talk about
football yes so I said yes so they had a
format where was like during the season
every day and it was more or less like
you're 30 to 60 minutes of NFL news
consumption for the day sure that's what
I did and then after three years kind of
built that up and went out on my own
it's been a great venture for me but in
hindsight I would never do a podcast
that's time sensitive because I you know
during the season it's everyday Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday probably and
I don't want to change it now because I
don't wanna change you know I've got a
pretty good built up already at that
point you put up that Tuesday podcast at
like 8:00 in the morning and then at
10:30 news breaks right okay so that
stinks but then I'm coming back the next
day yeah so but like I tell people now
like I go to the NFL's broadcast boot
camp every year and there's always guys
there I know like how what should I do
when I'm talking to you know a bunch of
guys like Penn State guys I was like
Matt McGloin sure and Mike Mao D and
those guys I'm like whatever you do
don't start a time-sensitive podcast and
don't start a podcast that you know
talking about the NFL or talking
college football ma you know you guys
should do you shot a podcast that's
called legends of Penn State football
and you interview Matt Millen and Franco
Harris because then people can listen to
them whenever in forever
yeah like my Monday podcast like during
the season maybe that's a bad example
cuz I'm breaking down all the games but
a lot of times by the time I do the next
podcast nobody gives a [ __ ] about the
podcast before I know and it makes it
really hard to get huge numbers that way
you I feel like you get huge numbers if
people can always care about your
podcast if that makes that what you're
doing right now all these interviews
you've been doing which have been
awesome you had my college roommate Kyle
Brant on that's so funny that you guys
were roommates together was it assigned
roommate or did you guys pick each other
because you played football together
football fraternity and same eating club
if we're gonna stay on the topic yeah so
how much did you weigh like either in
your peak playing career I would
typically go into training camp between
320 and 325 Wow and like back then I
could and what do you think your natural
weight was I don't know what that means
you know in all sincerity always asked
me that and I never know I'll say this
because I don't think people realize
that offensive linemen have to work to
be big they just think they're naturally
huge
well there's you're either one or two
ways there are some guys that have to
like get up every three hours and have
six more hard-boiled eggs Trent Brown
was in here that man doesn't need to eat
to gain weight red brown fit in this
room it's ink I thought it was gonna
break the chair is that not unbelievable
his hands like are so big but no he's a
kind of guy that has to eat healthy and
train but then there's that I would
imagine the smaller white guards that
have to be the ones that bulk up yeah so
I I actually now have to work harder to
stay down hmm I was I'm not a guy that
had to work to get up I know guys that
nearly had to work to stay at 300 pounds
I wasn't like that but dude I would I
would go to Chipotle and get two
burritos and just house them both I
remember in high school when I was
really growing did it feel like a free
pass because everyone's out there
worrying about that stuff and when
you're an offensive lineman you're kind
of like [ __ ] you meeting - I never it
didn't seem like a free pass because
just seemed normal it only seemed like a
free pass if the person I was with
commented about it gotcha
but I'm not even joking like in high
school when I was really growing I went
from 5-9 159th grade six foot one
seventy tenth grade six three to ten six
for 250 I would go to subway I would get
two foot longs double meat bacon and my
you know we'd be with like girls I guess
like a Friday night girl we get a six
inch like turkey or something look you
know I would get two foot longs and
destroy them on wheat though because I'm
crazy healthy like that on weight so I
would have to footlongs
look and that was like my normal and
then I see that you wrote when you
retired you did an hour of cardio every
morning at 5:00 a.m. Cheerios and skim
milk at 780 calories okert at 10:00
turkey sandwich with mustard on wheat
bread at 1:00 applet for two chicken
tenders on the George Foreman grill you
were eating like around a thousand
calories when you were retired like when
you retire did you just say I'm shedding
all of this so I've heard that you only
go one of two ways
you either balloon up or you drop it
right away I hurt my neck on the wedge
against the Ravens I herniated my c5 c6
bruised my spinal cord and I was so
upset about that you know football was
my identity you know it's not like like
you know I have other interests in life
and like I went to prints or whatever
but like what anywhere I went starting
like junior year high school people were
like there's Ross Tucker the football
player and really like her comma
football yes and even since sixth grade
even if other people didn't look at me
like that since sixth grade I looked at
myself like that
like I liked being like I you know I
always see these guys that are like I'm
so much more than a football player I
can do this argue like and that's fine
like I never I never had a desire to be
that guy that beats my chest is I'm so
much more than folklore like no on Ross
Tucker the effing football play like
that I love that so to have that in one
snap I said to the doctor I'm like what
do you think he's like he did some of my
fingers and toes that showed I bruised
my spinal cord damn when I did my c5
he's like dude you're 28 he probably
didn't say dude but he said you're 28
you know you went to Princeton like
you gotta get a real job now he said
once your spinal cords been compromised
or affected he's like it's just not so I
was real upset about that and the only
way I could get that energy out
I had to immediately put all of my
football energy into something else yeah
and all of the sadness and anger and
whatever about it being over finally I
put it all into losing weight and I'm
not kidding you when I tell you I think
when I got hurt I was like 315 it was
like third preseason game by Christmas I
was 248 is that how do you I don't think
so like 70 I don't think it is and I
wasn't and I wasn't lifting at all
I was rehabbing my neck and just doing
an hour cardio in the morning and then
another like 30 minutes to an hour in
the afternoon you said my diet I was so
hungry at him and so miserable that when
I ate those two George Foreman chicken
tenders at 7:00 I would go to bed at
like 7:30
my wife was studying for Business School
because she knew my football was over as
like her turn yeah yeah and she was like
go to bed because I was so you just
snapped I was so angry I was so hungry
yeah he's like if it got past the gate
30 I would be like she could just tell I
was angry I was so hungry she's like
just go to bed Ross I don't wanna fight
with you tonight just go to bed don't
listen I've been doing for it's 33 days
of eating like a homie because the
listeners are the 33% so we've all been
challenging ourselves to eat healthy and
one of the questions that I get a lot is
what do you do at night when it sucks
and the advice I usually say is brush
your teeth because you don't want to eat
anything but I'm glad you're saying this
so that people out there know that
they're not alone because that nighttime
is the worst it is the worst you know
what's weird so I did like the small
meals every three hours for like ten
years and it kind of stopped working and
by the way so I started do mediate
you're gonna love this started you media
and I have a huge head right so a little
amount of a big head I've like a size 8
or whatever so Wow so I um I went on
outside the lines with Bob Lee and it
was some like the real
yeah it was some like real serious topic
and I'm wearing like a suit and tie okay
and I didn't lift for five months and
you know my neck was a little atrophied
cuz I heard it right so I'm on with Bob
Leon outside London I'm in some studio
here in New York I think
and Bob's asking me a question I'm like
that's a good question Bob and look like
a bobble head bobble head dude polit my
wife watch that I'm like what do you
think she's like I think you need to do
some shrugs or something
she's like you look like a bobble she's
like you look like a skinny nerd you
look like like my wife's the person that
she fell in love with me when I was 300
pounds yeah she'll say to me what is
that
I can feel a rib what is that like I
have and like she's actually wants you
bigger yes she's like she's like high
but she she like hi I'm Adam I the
opposite
I literally swing like it I get I
haven't seen a rib and I go damn yeah
dude your voice is unbelie-- you know
what do people say I said when I hear a
voice I think um what do you hear us I
hear exactly you just did it I hear like
late night late night radio disc jockey
yesterday the other day producer David
and I were we're talking about doing
fake radio promos because I love when I
call on a radio stations and it's like
Charlotte North Carolina and the promos
for the radio stations themselves are
always ridiculous it's like do you like
a sports radio station that punches you
in the face and like I love that [ __ ]
what's really funny is I don't think
I've talked about it here I hated my
voice for a long time I went to Syracuse
my teachers used to be on CBS Nightly
News
you see posters of Mike Tirico and Bob
Costas and all of their voices are
perfect and Here I am with the voice of
a 50 year old divorcee and I'm like this
is [ __ ] awful say divorce Hagen
divorce a this is awesome now it's
become something I like yeah and you
know smoke and daddy cigars and drink
and all that bourbon accentuated it more
so you have like an awesome voice that's
like a big that's a real positive I'm
working on it
yeah so now you like well now now you
have me thinking about it so now I'm
gonna live no but do you do do you smoke
cigars and drink like intent like there
are people
daddy cigars are there people god I
gotta get are there people that there
are there used to be people that like
smoke cigarettes
yeah like under the table while they're
doing the news right purpose no no on
pert no they do it on purpose for their
voice you know you're not doing it more
your voice no no it's just uh yeah yeah
at this point though my my brother makes
fun of me a lot because if I smoked a
Daddy cigar I start sounding like Batman
like I'll just be sitting there and be
like why are we doing this there's no
reason for us to be around he's like
stop with the character actor you
mentioned the Eagles before yeah to me I
am family friends with Justin pew who's
now down the Arizona Cardinals and I
know that it bothered him for a while
that here he was playing for the New
York Giants a first-round pick yeah and
all of his friends are still wearing
Eagles jerseys to those games you played
for Washington and Dallas yeah and yet
you were raised in a hardcore Eagles
country yeah and I always hear NFL
players tell me as soon as you get
drafted the fandom washes away I don't
know if that's the case with you well no
I'll tell you what happened so what
happens is when you're like a junior and
senior in high school and then when
you're a college football player you
kind of you don't lose your fandom but
you're so invested in what you're doing
at that point that you're not as
invested in the Eagles got you're not
really looking at the fandom but you
might be looking at a guard that's
playing your position like you might be
looking at John welborne and looking at
like what he does ya know I was still
like if you asked her main mayberry
right if you asked me in college and I
was still and I love him if you asked me
in college I was still an Eagles fan hmm
but like on Sundays we would have
meetings the day after a game I didn't
get chance to watch that many Eagles
games I do remember this though it might
I think it was like my junior year of
college they had this thing where it's
like it was the Eagles put like a
Thursday night game okay
and it was a bus like you know some
students sponsored thing was a bus to go
to the Eagles game I was like I'm in it
was free you know like 10 bucks so I'm
in I got one of my teammates to go with
me know a couple actually one was from
Philly went to Cardinal O'Hara then was
from del Barton we get on the bus they
get tickets to the game you're on the
bus so we go this is this might have
been 2000 99 or 2000 so we get on the
bus and I'm just hammering your daddy
sodas
yeah I'm just hammering daddy sodas the
whole time right we get there and this
is legitimately funny we go down I think
they might have been playing the Rams I
go down during old-line warm-ups and
this point I'm feeling pretty good right
I go down during old-line wharfs and the
old line is like doing their drills and
I am screaming I think Steve Everett was
there Center dice and I'm screaming at
Trey Thomas I'm going nobody respects
you true no respect you it's time to
hurt some respect and Trey looks at me
and points to me and I keep saying he
keeps going like he's got me like I'm
like that nobody respects you and the
thing that's so funny about it is
literally three years later I'm starting
for the Dallas Cowboys against the
Eagles in a late season Saturday night
ESPN game and the thing that's weird
about it it wasn't weird really wearing
a Redskins helmet or even like wearing a
Cowboys I'm like like wearing a cowboy
something it was cool just cowboy Stern
I mean like yeah you know I grew up with
Emmitt Smith and all those good I was
blocking for Emmitt Smith yeah that's
crazy yeah it is it is but what was
weird was playing against the Eagles
that was a little weird yeah the only
thing I ever felt was well first of all
during the game during that day I'm
sitting in the hotel cuz it's a Saturday
night game one of my buddies calls me
because my rookie year for the Redskins
I didn't play much okay and then my
second year for the Cowboys I'm actually
starting the game at left guard my buddy
calls me and he's like I still can't
believe you're really going through with
this man I was like what are you talking
about he's like dude the only thing I
can figure is that you're gonna let
Corey Simon and Darwin Walker get a
couple sacks to make sure we get home
field advantage that's I was like dumb
that you work at Verizon and the mall
they don't even know you exist there is
no we he's like that's all he's like
that's all I can say so what was weird
about it was weird to be out there and
like you know Trey Thomas is playing or
Hugh Douglas and Dawkins
who three years earlier when I went to
that Thursday night game I was like yeah
you I was like let's go talk now I'm out
there like trying to kill those guys
like I'm playing against him so it was
weird to go against the green it was
like I have an unhealthy obsession with
Brian Dawkins oh he's the best ever he's
legal ever he's all of my passwords
he was my AI m screen name I saying this
to Kyle last week but to face him I'm
curious when you would when they would
watch the film of him like what was the
the reverence that coaches and players
like whether it's him or an IDI read
someone yeah I'm not just not just
safeties but like a Ray Lewis when you
guys were facing somebody special
what was that week of practice like
hearing about that guy did they become
mythological or would the coach's break
them down and make it because I'm here
in Belichick beginning of the week he
builds him up end of the week he breaks
him down the opponent how would they
handle like superstars though to guys
like you I think it varied some coaches
would say hey you better you better
bring your lunch pail this week like
you're going against even like I
remember starting a game against the
Raven it was a Kelly Greg was a huge
pain but he was like 511 280 and I was
you could never get any leverage on him
he's a fireplug yeah exactly he was a
yeah exactly so I but I remember but
sometimes they would try and downplay
the guy like if they thought you liked
if they thought it depends on who they
were talking to like if they thought you
needed confidence they'd be like you got
this he's older now you know he's
overrated so you could kind of tell what
they thought about you and your
confidence based on how they would
describe it I do remember this though
guy tell people all the time the best
player I ever played against was Ray
Lewis and it was 2004 I would start at
center for the bills in Baltimore
and I could just tell by the scheme that
I was gonna have to block him a lot and
to your point the one practice squad
offensive lineman was like yo tuck you
got a blocker a like almost every play
and I said you know F him I'm gonna kill
him I'm gonna get I must buy time to
make my statement to the rest of the
league I'm gonna make a name for myself
yeah F him I'm gonna kill him that is
not what happened in the game it's like
pausing and it's like that yeah 20
minutes later that was not what happened
I'm not even but here's the two things
that you need to know everybody
listening needs to know about Ray Lewis
first of all more than any guy ever
played against he called out what play
we were running about 50% of the time
based on our formation and modi's would
say this too that he would he would be
at the line of scrimmage and Ray would
go the running right up the gut to the
left and then Simms would go holy crap
this running back and he'd be like sorry
bro because he just knew the play it was
it film study was it just having like an
insurance film study like there was a
place I supposed to block him was like a
sweep to the right I come on for the
sideline legendary old line coach Jim
McNally he's like tuck you got to get
ray I'm like yeah let me see the
Polaroids cuz back then they had yes
there was at the Polaroid right before
the snap right after the snap so he
gives it I given him and I show it to
him when I snap the ball he was already
he was outside the titan-1 yard off the
ball I give it I go you guys better call
a different play or different formation
he looks at he goes oh [ __ ] yeah you're
right sorry and he did that half the
time and then Adam even when I dig up to
block him okay I'd go up to block him
with the butt of his hands the hard part
of his hand yeah every time he would go
poop hit me right I don't have I have
short armors my worst attribute he would
hit me right out of the show right in
the shoulder points he would lock me out
shed me discard me and then make the
tackle to the point where best technique
of any linebacker ever wanting it I came
back to the huddle and McGee he's like
and cuz I'm again he knows right look
McGee he's like tuck o Willis McGahee
yeah Willis McGahee McGee's like tuck
maybe just try to cut him or something
so finally the next time we run the same
sprint draw
like this today and I just dive at his
knees yeah I didn't get him down but he
had to protect his meat like that you
just load him down
so McGee he got like 15 yards nice and
that's why I just started doing I did
ray say anything to you after that no ok
but I could not block him like this [ __ ]
talker not in that game he was and no he
didn't need to be he was just killing me
so he I tell us we all time because some
people think Ray Lewis or any walk of
life but rail is a think big fast strong
ferocious the two things that made him
the best guy ever won against knowing
what play was coming and his technique
they take no talent mmm like that's just
the time he put in that week no talent
ok did you hear what Brian Flores is
doing in Miami no apparently there's a
huge wall near their practice field that
says TNT which means takes no talent and
anytime somebody [ __ ] up at practice
they have to run and touch the wall and
come back so if the center and the
quarterback have a failed exchange he
goes that took no talent get to the wall
and so it's just discipline and all that
just the fact you said I love that I'm
obsessed with Brian Flores apparently is
just walking around going Rennes to
every day like he is I was joking about
what Patricia pretends to be
we're like he took all those lessons
from Belichick I'm not [ __ ] on
Patricia Brian Flores is like the 38
year old military version real enactment
of it like I feel like he's Bella checks
toy soldier and I'm so excited for what
he's gonna do in Miami do you want to
hear something crazy when I got signed
by the Patriots in o-5 Patricia was
assistant offensive line coach
it was midway through the year so
Patricia had to stay up with me all
night because I had to be ready to play
in that game so Patricia who everybody
knows is the D coordinator Lions head
coach Isis offensive line coach with me
all week and Brian Flores was a scout he
wasn't here on the coaching staff he was
a scout so I know both of their rises
make sense to you now yeah both very
bright yeah Patricia I went to like RPI
or rit or something and floors went to
BC you could just tell now they're very
different in the sense that you know
Patricia's got the beard and doesn't
really care that much about that was my
point is that when Brian Flores says
don't like details matter and he's got
like a six-pack abs and like traps and
works out at 4:30 in the morning you
naturally believe that guy yes but
Patricia says it I go you haven't shaved
in two months so like obviously the
details are okay for some of them you
know I mean like just as a human I would
react differently to that I never did it
that way but yeah I think you have a
better army just like aesthetically but
Flores is the man I think I I think he's
gonna be successful I'll tell you why
they're doing it the right way yeah
everything they're doing to build for
2020 the only move that they made I
don't understand is the Fitzpatrick move
like if you're trying to lose don't
bring in Fitz I don't know because to me
if you're trying to lose Fitzpatrick is
the perfect guy to cover it up if you're
up 14 nothing
there's no quarterback for them to have
that evaporate the second half with five
quick picks but it doesn't win three or
four games for you yeah I know he's
gonna he's gonna win through like you
don't want that I don't know if he's the
perfect tanking quarterback or the worst
tanking quarterback cuz like if you're
really a team that could win one he
might win you four but if you're a team
that might win six he might win you
three I was doing that on my show today
I was doing favorite journeyman
quarterback of all time
Oh with Josh McCown retiring it's some
of the names that people bring up you're
like like JT O'Sullivan and like but
without having any prep Shaun Hill is
one of my favorite yes Jon Kitna
yes I'm just thinking all Detroit Lions
right now Dave Craig I saw I was
watching an old documentary about jay-z
and all these rappers going on tour and
while the rapper's was wearing a bobby
hoing jersey I would say bubby Brister
yeah they're one that I really liked
tommy maddox is I think the journeyman
quarterback yeah other leagues but but
the journey like tommy maddox and then
Kurt Warner now there's a Hall of Fame I
wouldn't put him as that but tommy
maddox being kicked out of the league
and having to use the XFL to come back
in the league yeah and playing in a
playoff game talk about journeyman I
mean that's a fun here's this question
would you consider like Mark Brunell or
Jeff Garcia journeyman or did they have
too much success with the Jags and
Niners i was a-sayin considered a 30 is
not a journeyman
because i believe he was the face of the
jaguar
yes I look at Jeff Garcia and the amount
of disrespect he got and how many teams
he played on I would say he was even
though he had a few years where like his
quarterback rating was like the highest
of all time with the Niners yeah that
Niners team never felt like like with
like tio never felt like his team right
I think if it was ever your team I don't
consider you a journeyman yeah yeah
Brunel it was his team yeah McGowan
never had a team never like Brian Hoyer
is a journey thing about McCown I
remember interview and Emmett Smith
everybody has respect for him account
like even Emmitt Smith was like his
rookie year it was like my last year
like so McCowan's like journey into the
NFL was my like swan song yeah he's like
I [ __ ] love Josh McCown and I love
Emmitt I fell people all the time so it
was weird so I'm in the huddle with
Emmett right and it's so funny cuz NFL
Films just sent me my career highlights
which they do now and I was like
laughing about how long I was like nine
minutes in credit they got a good 90
minutes out of it yeah and it's awesome
because I showed my daughters they had
never seen it and a lot of it is Emmitt
scoring a touchdown and then me running
in and hugging him yeah yeah my
daughters are like daddy why do you hug
so much I'm like well because I'm happy
and that's the all-time leading rusher
in NFL history but I tell people how
about Emmett that's so funny is so first
of all he'd been playing I was like 10
right but he was small and he was slow
but somehow he always got yards what do
you think it was we had the worst
offensive line the league he was really
small he's so slow yeah and somehow any
little nook or crevice or cranny yeah
and he could follow blocking it's so
interesting you say that because I think
Emmett is defined by the offensive lines
of the early 90s the Larry Allen lines
and all that where we discredit him
because the line was so good exactly as
he played longer that didn't stay in the
test of time I'll tell people that say
that watch 2002 because we stunk our
quarterbacks a friend of mine I was in
his wedding Chad Hutchinson but we we
did not have a great passing game Jason
Garrett the instant guy jesseman the
o-line a journeyman yet the old line was
not good
and yet Emmett I remember on
Thanksgiving we beat the Redskins here
like a hundred fifty yards like he he
now we were the first team in like 11
years he didn't get a thousand yards yet
like 960 so we left yeah it was bad cuz
the last game that was like all we were
trying to do yeah was give him a
thousand yards because like the season
was over you were I'm sure for him it
was vision when you talk about Ray you
talk about guys like Zack Thomas tell me
guys like junior say al that ability to
read and I hear that you actually laid a
smack on junior say ah one time yeah who
told you that one don't worry about I
dude you're you are a well-researched so
one of my favorite plays ever I'm
playing its 2003 I'm right guard for the
bills I pull right on like a sweep to
the right right kind of a they call it a
G scheme right so the guard were you for
the story can I ask you a question yeah
when you come around to the right what
is the best situation that you could see
and what's the worst situation that you
can see because I know that for a second
you're kind of blind right you're kind
of turned that corner yeah so what's the
best thing you can see in the worst
thing that you can see so it's weird
because they're the exact same thing
what the best thing you can see is
nothing because it's like wow it's
really well blocked and I can go up on
the next love right but that's also the
worst thing cuz that probably means that
the linebacker is coming to blow up your
frickin hip as hard as he can and you
you're pulling around the tight end of
the tackle you can't see him but he sees
you right and he knows exactly what
people don't realize is like you'll see
on TV like a 3 or 20 pound guy go flying
you have no power in your back hip like
when you pull and run there's no power
if someone hits you like that hits you
just collapse yeah you go flying there's
no power in your back hip so those guys
are taught when a lineman gets out there
on a screen or lineman pulls they're
taught to back hip you because there's
no power there Wow and so if there's
nothing there you're looking inside
because he's like I'm about to get
killed so anyway so I'm there and say I
was one he knew what was coming before
the play right so I have to block him he
starts to slide out before the play I'm
like
my gosh so I snap and he hits me he
jacks me up like four yards in the
backfield because he knew what was
coming he went on the end the line of
scrimmage
came screaming off so I hit him we
engage Travis Henry was a running back
Travis stops runs in the opposite
direction
ok so runs away from us where the play
is supposed to go so I'm unlocked up
with you your junior and junior sees
that T hands going that way so he
disengages from me and starts to go that
way back towards the center towards
Travis Henry I have no idea what
possessed me to do this but any other
thing I would have done would have been
a holding penalty right and and as you
had one harm yeah and it would have been
blatantly obvious to the refs right like
blatantly obvious so for some reason my
gut reaction was to take my right hand
and open hand and hit him in the back of
the head as hard as I possibly could ok
like my I guess my thought was the
momentum I didn't think anything it's
just a reaction but it worked because he
was using all his force to disengage and
go that way so then when you hit him in
the head that way he he went like this
he looked like he got shot by a sniper
and what and fell down in the ground and
he gets up and gets in my face he goes
and I'm just smiling laughing he's like
what's the [ __ ] funny I'm like dude
you go to the Hall of Fame some day I
just totally smoked you that was
hilarious
I just Deacon Jonah crap is that illegal
like can you no you can't do that you
can't hit a guy in the head with an open
hand like that but they didn't see it
it's like things happen so fast that
they can't did that make the 9 minute
highlight reel no I wish it had you know
what's funny though the highlight reel
they send you comes with no audio so I
had a buddy of mine put some songs so
he's like what songs you want I'm like I
don't know no I well I hadn't put a
couple glory days by Springsteen a
couple imagine dragons
I don't know if he could have found like
the NFL Films music but then I was
showing it to my mom and her boyfriend
and I was like telling him what to watch
for and they're like this is what the
audio needs to be you know for posterity
it needs to be you cuz I'm like I might
watch this at dinner display Gerard war
and tell him he's gonna break my arm
because it literally was a play in 2004
against the Browns
I'm blocking Gerard warned you by the
way spit in my face earlier in the game
spit like a lot did you say anything to
warrant it what's that did you earn that
no in in training camp we had had
practices with them yeah and I did him
dirty a couple times what does that mean
like some under uppercuts uh one time
were you a training camp fighter for
sure yeah for sure so one time so one
time he went down and in so you know
these teams all have these training camp
practices together Buffalo's did it with
Cleveland and one time like he came on a
stunt and tripped and went to the ground
and I like speared him always on the
ground you guys love doing that [ __ ] I
love it and then in one-on-ones Sam wife
told me I was his hero when he saw that
on tape
and then and then we didn't want to want
I know he's all pissed at me now right
so I know he's gonna come off firing low
and try to kill me because no matter
what I joined that other drill right so
as soon as the snap comes rather than
trying to bull like you know engage with
him I just lift up and take my two fists
and thunderstrike the back of his head
because he came off that low Wow but I
just want whap and he went face first
right everybody's laughing and it was
glorious and this was one-on-one so it's
in front of everybody right and this is
one-on-ones there in practice right so
he can't get me he can't get back at me
when we play him like week 11 week 12
and he was waiting for it so
first play the game after the play he
had a mouthful of water that he must
learn on purpose spits all the water in
my face he's the first play with water
in his mouth yeah he must have there's
no way anybody is that much spit it was
like a lot like it was like a lot of
water
he's second play um second play Alvin
McKinley did something you react to
getting spit in your face I was like
what the hell was that and I going back
in the huddle
here's the thing though like then the
next series they came out and they did
the same thing like they didn't spit at
me but like they were pushed
after the play so their coaches clearly
it's shown them the video of what I did
from right so then there's a TV timeout
and I'm not even kidding you Adam ask
any guy in the Buffalo Bills during the
TV timeout I walked over to the Browns
defensive line and I said hey guys I'm
sick of it now I'm breaking one of your
[ __ ] legs on the next play and I
walked back to the huddle okay I was
just sick if I go up during a TV timeout
I walked over I'm breaking one of your
[ __ ] legs on the next play and I walk
back I know and we came out for that
next play and Alvin McKinley is like
talk talk we're cool man we're cool it's
good cuz you know an offensive lineman
you can like there's five off his
linemen there's four D lineman you can
get guys in a position if I can get you
in a position where I can put a lot of
force on the side here let everybody
watch somebody else and you hit him from
the side yes I can break your leg if I
want to and so Dan they wild even think
I so they were like they were like they
were like it's cool man we're caught
it's over now it's over now well then
later in that game I'm going unblocking
jarred Warren he had a couple screws
loose
I'm blocking him and I'm getting a good
block on him we run in for a touchdown
now you can see on the video when he's
like at the three yard line and they're
running backs like the five he stops
trying to get off the block and goes
like this and takes my arm and puts me
in an arm bar like this
Gerard more puts me an arm bar like this
and says I'll break your [ __ ]
on I'll draw it no no no no I thought
he's gonna music I'm like no no it's
cool draw is that plays over plays over
and he didn't do it but I never been in
arm before arm bar before with the six
three three or 30-pound he was enormous
monster so quick and he and he said just
like a hombre cue more for all I was
scared shitless dude I thought you were
gonna say after you spit in your face
that you stood there the entire TV
timeout were like my dad old Ace Ventura
thing and like you just my dream is that
Gerard Warren spent those eleven weeks
with a picture of you on the wall doing
target practice just spitting at it you
know what's funny now is that moment
Ross you know it's funny now
a thousand percent somebody would have
video of that a thousand percent the guy
would say something out after the game
yeah and it would become like a huge
social media many times I got spit on
twice Langston more from the bangles
spit in my face later that season I
never say anything anybody about either
one that's why in that era when it was
caught on tape it was such a big deal
when bill Romanowski spitting that guy's
face what was it JJ Stokes that was
enormous when I actually got a chance
one time to spend an afternoon with
buddy Ryan when he was like like very
older his granddaughter or pretty much
granddaughter is one of my best friends
in Kentucky and she hooked it up to
where I had to spend the whole day with
him and we were talking about that
occurrence on the sidelines when he went
to go punch Gilbert Gilbride in the head
and I said I said the fact that the
camera was on you guys I go how many
coaches in that time probably fought
each other in the silent there's
probably a lot I don't know how many
went yeah full punch to the face yeah
but the fact that the cameras were there
I mean that's why it lives in infamy
yeah we're like overrun with all these
clips right and sideline shots and
handheld camera phones and all that
right right it's totally totally changed
but I never said like I didn't say
anything like how do you I guess how do
you breathe even bringing that about for
the game like I was gonna be like oh
yeah that one dude spit on me like we
won they lost yeah I just won that was I
do remember the dr. Langston more in
Cincinnati it's better on me Marvin
Lewis was their head coach and I had
played with Marvin with the red teens no
to and I was screaming at Marvin to let
him back in the game because the refs
saw it yeah and didn't throw a fight the
refs just like told me off the field or
something I'm like bring him back out
here bring him back out here and that
that game that's it another guy got to a
quick story yeah about that game so
we're up you know Justin Smith of course
yeah so we're up like in that game I
want to say oh by the way that was the
game atom 2004 at Cincinnati might be
like week 15
that was a game where number 85 for the
Buffalo Bills Jason Peters blocked the
punt picked up a returner for a
touchdown number 85 for the 2004 Buffalo
Bills her genes poetic about Jason
Peters recently unbelievable so why is
it why is
resonating with you so much right now I
heard you on Dave damaged sex podcast
just talk about him still being able to
play at this level like what is it about
him that's speaking to you right now
dude he's like 38 years old we played
together in 2004 it hurts my back and I
weigh like 255 now to stand at a bar for
my third beer like if it's like 2530
minutes my guys sit down this guy is
still 350 and I went to Eagles mini camp
last week or whenever that was he moves
around like he goes gazelle hmm I mean
he's like flying around the field it's
unbeliev I get the vibe from him when he
got hurt a year or two ago and got
carted off the field and you saw the
impact that he has on his teammates and
the way they speak about him was he
always like a super leader not at all
really if you would have told me that
he'd become what he's become I would
have been shocked first of all they cut
him at first cuts the bills did but he
was still in the hotel I was like why
are you still here he's like oh they're
bringing me back on practice squad but
back then the first cut went down in 65
and they needed other dudes to get
through the last preseason game so they
cut him at the first cut Jason Peters
was cut at the first cut to 65 from 80
to 65 Jason Peters was cut hanging out
in the hotel because we were bringing
him back on practice squad as a tight
end it's unbelievable and then I
remember when they moved him I was the
day they moved in offensive line okay he
was playing tight end they had him come
down and do one-on-ones and I was never
very good at one-on-ones you know it's a
very difficult role for off until except
for that one time is horrible I guess
Rod Warren yeah but it's a very
difficult drill for an offensive lineman
Jason came down they put him at left
tackle nobody could beat him dude he was
better in five seconds then I was he was
better at doing something if I that I
had been for 18 years
it was on a he had no idea what he's
doing his technique was all over the
place
he just said stay in front of that guy
yes his feet were that good his arms
were that long now I'm talking like
Aaron showable like they put like some
legit rush and like show if they're like
let me I gotta go nope
they couldn't get anywhere but so what
happens you guys are just looking at
each other being like well what the [ __ ]
like like yeah like the coaches are like
this is amazing the offensive linemen
are like I mean [ __ ] I think you gotta
be kidding me yeah this is not right
that's awesome and and what's crazy is I
remember he had like a souped-up Impala
I remember that I remember that he had a
souped-up Impala and I also remember he
the the PlayBook did not come naturally
to him so even his second year after all
the OTAs after all the mini camps after
all training camp he was not the bat he
didn't know he did not start they didn't
trust him enough to be the backup tackle
he was the number four tackle because
those guys don't even suit up half-lift
he didn't suit up because what would
happen is if the if the corner blitz off
the edge or he just didn't forget like
that I already the blitz
responsibilities did not come really
naturally for him so which is why I was
so high on this Milotic kid you know for
people who don't know the Eagles have a
Australian rugby dude who's like 6 9 370
moves great he never played football
before Jason at least been playing
football forever
I'm watching Jordan my lot on last year
looking awesome and looking like he
knows what he's doing yeah like he was
better Jordan my lot it was better last
year in those preseason games as a
rookie 21 year old then Jason was his
second year hmm so that's why I said I
said I got a lot of attention I said I
don't think he's guys gonna be a starter
anymore I think he's gonna be like an
all-pro like he's that he's acting Andre
Dillard's interesting for the Eagles
yeah well a good two thoughts one is you
know my louder went on IR with the back
injury
oh that's last year last year so as a
guy that had a back surgery in Buffalo I
was never the same
yeah when I hear back I just go they'll
never be the same again I've never heard
a guy say I used to have a bad back yeah
you still always have a bad back in some
way shape or form like talk about Tiger
Woods that's all I ever hear yes I don't
know like maybe my lot is totally fine
it's practicing everything but that
might have been a concern and also
there's still some unknown about my
lotta right
whereas I think my guess is the Eagles
felt like it's just too important of a
position and I would say we to lose the
chance lose Jason Peters and you see
trying to get vitai out yes and
especially with Brandon books Brooks
coming off an Achilles all the shuffling
that might need to happen and you don't
really get a franchise left tackle at 22
in the draft every year correct it kind
of worked out in their face Sager and
and I think their thought is if my lot
ends up being unbelievable then great
maybe we can trade him or trade diller
or maybe we'll just have three awesome
tackles you know I mean like yeah the
Eagles have a history
whether it's Runyon and trade Thomas or
whatever they want to be good at tackle
that is very very important to them um I
just realized - you're doing the
preseason games for the Eagles this year
yes everyone's talking about the impact
of Mayock going the Raiders you're like
holy crap this opens up so what's weird
is I did the NFL games for Westar one
every Sunday for like seven years
Westwood one radio a national game this
past year was the first year west or one
decided not to do Sunday afternoon games
so instead I did Eagles pregame for WIP
radio which is the station of Billy if
you're from there you know I people
listening won't know but it's the
station so I didn't googles pregame so
part of that is you know with the Eagles
and whatever so I'm doing their pregame
for their Saints playoff game and I'm
sideline for Webster one so it was
awesome I call it the vaunted double dip
because I get paid to do Eagles pregame
and then sideline for western ones like
yeah Jack's from both so that week
Mayock takes the Raiders GM job out of
nowhere and so literally I'm on the
elliptical at the hotel and Howie
Roseman comes on the elliptical right
next to me and we're gonna and I and you
know he's got a big game that day you
don't mean and he knows me we're not
like friends but he knows me
I said hey Howie I just want you to let
you know like I would love that
that preseason gig you shot you shot
your shot right yeah I would love that
preseason gig you know it would be a
dream job for me yeah and he's like he's
like God he's like that's not my
department
he's like but if they ask me you
you know I you know I think you do a
great job basically and then I told the
guy that's in charge at the game I said
look I know this is the last thing
you're thinking about right now
but I just want I just want to say well
I'm in person like I've been watching
those games since I was six years old I
can't member being at the Jersey Shore
and they would want to go to Springer's
for ice cream
I'd be like nope it's the third quarter
against the Jets preseason game number
four I am watching this you're me like I
was that guy in k4 Mike get on the field
so anyway so I so I just I just what
moves a dream job and so with Mike
leaving you know and I since I'd worked
for them that yeah ended up working out
so it's cool like you know how how you
know Hastings Nebraska Hastings huh you
know it's a tough business
yeah so when things work out such that
somebody gets a dream gig it's really
cool it's not like I'm doing my night
football it's not like it's a whole
season but for those four games that's
like it sounds weird to say but like on
some level it's a bigger deal for me
than my nice long it's the Eagles yeah
you mean like it's the Eagles and it's
kind of cool too because reading is an
hour west of Philly and it's kind of a
rough City it's kind of fallen on tough
times so it's really cool for people and
reading to see one of their guys
somebody from Redding is on the Eagles
broadcast not Philly you're gonna get an
article like the local paper
Oh thousand breeze I think they already
did that's a thousand percent thousand
percent I think I already did um did you
when you played on the Patriots did you
snap to Brady yeah in practice never in
a game all right so all I've ever heard
is that that exchange is where practice
starts and stops that if that's not
perfect that's all they're gonna focus
on that they can't start until the snaps
great and that if it's not going well
that's when Belichick is gonna come out
and go you know there's a kid at the
local high school that could do this
better than you
he either says that or he says you know
I remember he said one time he said you
know I sucked okay I really did I saw I
was not it was a snapper right he was a
long snap he's a he's like you think I
sucked he's like you know what I could
do I could snap the ball to the
quarterback this story I tell people
that I think is crazy and it kind of
goes back to the Ray Lewis thing a
little bit
is I played football for 18 years and
snapping the ball to a quarterback you
take the ball you propel it to your rear
and you're hitting the quarterbacks top
hand right it's the most mundane rote
thing you do so first thing to every
practice
it's so boring it's so stupid right and
you hate it you're like what a waste of
time yeah never had a quarterback that
cared nearly as much about it as Brady
when I practice and I was in the huddle
like in the spring he would come in the
huddle and they'd have him do everything
there I'm sure Chris has told you but
like change the protections and blah
blah blah he comes as a huddle and he
says all right Ross great snap you and
me great snap first in my eyes like that
he was every time every time you and me
great snap first Ross then he would call
the play
and at the time Adam I'm 26 maybe 27 I'd
played five years and if I heard 25
games played in 45 like ton of different
I'm a vest I'm a vet right when he would
look at me and say that in my head I was
like like just the way you would look at
me and say it and the story I tell
people is like you know it makes a sound
when you hit when you snap the ball when
you hit the hit the quarterbacks top
hand right it's and I equate it to a
clap right so if I make this clap like
that's a decent noise right but if you
really get a good clap you really can
hear it like it's there's a better noise
porkfish if it's a perfect if a perfect
clap is like a perfect snap it's like
like you really just hear it just just
pops still like when you DAP up your
friend and you hit it right and you look
at yes yes so Brady wanted that every
freaking time mm-hmm every - in his I
love the fact that Brady would like
probably go to like David Givens and
they like high-five and he would like do
it again
I want perfect high fives he's just
demanding in his head though in his
psycho head I mean there's a compliment
that perfect snap okay that that perfect
noise lets him go back from Center a
little bit faster and then lets him see
defense a little bit quicker without
readjusting the ball is not just on the
laces it lets him get the ball out a
little bit quicker to the right like in
his mind okay like I'll talk to college
or high school football teams and by the
time you're like a senior and you've
been doing the same drills for three
years you're like like you know whatever
I know how to do this drill it's like
the kick slide drill or whatever you're
like this is just stupid like I let's
get to the game like an NBA player doing
layup lines yeah guess what guess what
Brady doesn't look at it that way
there's like I tell people how can you
say any drill is stupid when Tom
freaking Brady cares that much about the
quarterback center snap when it's that
important to him in his mind every
second he's out there is a chance to get
a little bit better and everything he
does it's like why are you trying to do
it unless you're trying to do it
perfectly every time it's unbelievable
so you seem like somebody that can be
self-aware and that can also evaluate
like people's psychology was there ever
a time where you looked at Brady and you
were like you're [ __ ] crazy
like did you ever ask him why he's so
crazy no but we would like I'll give an
example of him being crazy I'll give you
a couple of examples a Jodie drills in
the offseason like the ladder drill you
know he was not good at that like he's
not athletic right to the point where at
times I remember people like laughing
like you know we don't go through the
drills you'd see like some of these DBS
and why does yeah like exactly yeah and
then Brady would go and when we'd all
kind of laugh left-right-left
yeah and he'd be like I'm doing it again
the guy had already won three super
wolves like nobody cared
he's like I'm doing it again like cuz he
thought I can do the agility drill a
little bit better I'll give you another
one this is this is this money better
than the snap one they signed me midway
through the oh five season one of those
weeks we had the rookie dinner so I go
out and the guys are asked me what it
was like in Buffalo because I played
three years in Buffalo and I'm like it
was awesome I love those guys we would
all get like a keg of Labatt Blue and go
to Bledsoe's house it was
great let's Oh always paid the tab it
was awesome right yeah she's like and
I'm saying like we love blood so cuz he
paid for everything and Brady's like
four people down but I can tell that and
I to this day I think he was kind of
listening right you could feel I could
feel that he like he was looking at the
people in front of him but I'm pretty
confident he was listening and somebody
like Steve Neil or somebody goes oh yeah
well because I've told him I was telling
how awesome blood to his because he
always pays the tab and and Steve Neil
said something like oh yeah Tom just
gets us rings Dan which was pretty
awesome right Craig but then the next
year during training camp okay we go to
a barbecue joint this is when the famous
chugging story was I'm not even telling
you about the famous chugging story
although your your your rankings are
while flawed hilarious good so we're in
a barbecue joint and this is before or
after no this is after the butt chugging
contest and we're about to go to
Talladega Nights
opening night okay it was an opening
night and Matt light had called ahead
I'll tell you that story saying so I go
to pay for my barbecue like $13 all
right I go up to the register brady
comes flying over flying over and he's
like he's like Ross I got it I got it
I'm like Tom it's $13 dudes like I got
it he looked at me like he was gonna
kick my ass he's like no I'm paying I
got it you will never convince me that
it wasn't somewhere in his head that he
heard me a year before in December or
November talking about how Bledsoe would
pay for everything you you kid and I
don't know any of this for a fact but
you could never convince me otherwise
that he didn't remember
Bledsoe would pay for everything and
there was no way he was gonna let me pay
for that and then do so we go to
Talladega Nights okay did you appreciate
that yeah I the guy is just awesome like
you think about like the Aaron Rodgers
where he's like you know these guys are
irrelevant
like Greg Jennings and you're Michael
Finley whatever I've never found a
single person that actually knows Brady
to say anything negative about him think
about that yeah the only thing I've
heard is that he's a little corny but
like that's not that bad
yeah I could I mean I didn't notice that
I the only knock I gave him was he would
blow dry his hair I was like come on
dude but then I thought he makes so much
money from his appearance
I'd be blow-drying my pew let me drive
blow drying everything if I was getting
money from that I'd be blow drying
everything that was the only knock
against him so anyways so that night
you'll appreciate this because you like
movies in your comedy guys so we're good
at Talladega Nights the movie starts at
9:00 it's opening night
Will Ferrell Talladega Nights oh I
thought you guys are going to the race I
didn't really sure go to the movies no
the movies okay who is during training
camp Belichick gave us the night off
because Harry Carson was getting in the
Hall of Fame oh sweet to get down there
yeah so not first you're last we get
there at 9:25 for a nine o'clock showing
but Matt late had called ahead and told
him we were coming and told him brady
was coming so they had the three best
rows of the theater marked off for us
but the computer system must have kept
printing out tickets so I'm not even
kidding there are people when we get
there like standing on the outsides of
the theater yet there's three rows
middle in the back reserved for us and
we just walk it I mean dude they had won
three Super Bowls in four years like we
just walked in and yeah they didn't know
what was going on so we sat down nobody
sat on either side of me meanwhile there
were like people standing Wow but they
had reserved those rows so I'm right
behind Brady and he's got a hat pulled
down he said next time at Castle in
front of me he got a hat pulled down
like this and by the time we got there
it was really the movie was dark so they
couldn't really see who was coming in
the people are in front of Brady and
there they turn around and you're Tom
Brady and they're like okay yeah you're
Tom Brady and they're like this I think
it's Brady like it was that dark that
you couldn't really tell they're like
four feet away from him
I think it's Brady and then the guy next
times like now he's like no I think it's
Brady
movies going on movie just starts and
Brady doesn't say a word so they didn't
know you know Brady didn't say anything
and then the movie starts and then they
had security for us when we were leaving
yeah but it's like funny like there's no
chance he like goes to a movie now that
I think I got there right at the end of
him being able to be somewhat normal
mmm like he can't do stuff like that no
he probably gets the movie sent to his
house and he watches him there yeah I
saw you say somewhere that Belichick is
very serious but also funny and I'm
curious what's the funniest thing you've
ever heard him say so and also what's
the thing he said to you that maybe hurt
your feelings well he only talked to me
four times awesome the whole time I was
there four times and it's and that's a
good thing because it's called for
conversations with Belichick and you
turn each conversation to a life lesson
there you go he um it's a hundred
percent
I'm sure Chris's told you it's a hundred
percent negative reinforcement there so
like your whole goal is to not be on the
8:00 a.m. low-light video so at 8:00
a.m. team meeting he'll first of all
tell you every question the media's
gonna ask you that day and is he right
and what your answer is yes you know he
does it I've seen him he will like on a
Wednesday morning when the first day of
the work week he'll be on the treadmill
with a yellow highlighter for like an
hour he goes through every clip about
the team everything he reads it yellow
highlighter highlights stuff so he can
tell by the Wednesday columns and the
Wednesday stories what the reporters
think the story line is so when he come
to the meeting he says they're gonna ask
you about the weather we're playing the
Jaguars in the playoffs right 2005
wild-card round they're gonna ask you
about the weather
weathers no factor weathers the same for
both teams like he literally went right
down the line and then you get out there
for the media and it would be that stuff
exact question I've always wanted to go
to a Belichick press conference and ask
him random questions about nothing
yes like I just want to be like what do
you think is the most I know if I said
what do these the most overrated movie
of all time he'd like turn and look away
yeah but I love when people ask him
historical questions or
football centric questions because the
stuff about this week it's never gonna
get answered I don't realize that he
prepared like that though never played
with the team organization that cared as
much about the media as the Patriots and
I remember thinking is this really this
important because they act like the
media doesn't matter but yet they're
really controlling it
oh they care oh I'll check him on your
podcast what would you talk to him about
that would be a lot of [ __ ] pressure
first of all I don't think you would
know definitely wouldn't right but if
for some reason he said I enjoyed
coaching you Ross I'm gonna do 20
minutes no you know what I would only
ask him about like back in the day or
X's and O's stuff I would ask him stuff
like anything because that's the only
good stuff you're gonna get from him
yeah but what do you we had so summer
you were talking about the four converse
and the 14 o'clock lowlights I'll tell
you the fourth thing so anyway your
whole goal is to not be on that
low-light video but I'll tell you the
four conversation we had the day they
signed me I'm Scott Pioli signs me I go
in the team meeting room I'm sitting
there and Belichick walks up like 14
stairs to come shake my hand I'm sitting
there and I see him coming and I start I
start to get up and he says stay in your
chair stay in your chair and hey shake
me I'm like okay and then he walks and
he goes back and that was the same day
that uh Brady said I'm snapping and
Brady Brady goes he does this to
everybody he goes hi Ross I'm Tom I was
like hi Tom nice to meet you and I'll
never forget that day by the way that
night my sister called me and she's like
did you meet Tom Brady
I said yeah Brin I'm kind of on the team
like I was snapping on the ball so you
were what I was snapping the ball she
said does that mean his hands were I
said yeah she said I've never wanted to
switch places with you so bad so so
anyway so that was the first
conversation is is him saying stay in
your chair stay in your chair yeah
stay in your chair he was you need to
get up second thing was that practice
that that week for some reason I fell on
the ground and that's a cardinal sin
because you fall on the ground
injuries he can hurt people yeah
so he had this hit his unbelievable way
of walking by you never stopping and all
I heard was from some corner in my ear
stay off the [ __ ] ground willya and I
look around and I don't even know like
who said it or what and all of a sudden
look over and Bella checks like eight
paces that way already so he saw me fall
down stay off the [ __ ] ground Willie
and I see him walk that way I was like
oh that must been him okay conversation
number two was converses number two
conversation number going to say that
you've used the word conversation a
little liberally here yeah I see origin
yes
you only comments he ever said to me
guys comment number three I like
conversation yeah conversation number
three we're playing the Jaguars in that
playoff game that week and my college
teammate Dennis Norman at Princeton was
starting a center for the Jaguars that
week and Belichick like again I hear
this noise out of nowhere it comes from
behind and I just hear somebody say we
got half the [ __ ] Princeton football
Princeton line in this game and I'm
looking around and he's over there and
it was Belichick again and I wanted to
tell him something about Dennis but they
never asked me and he walked away and
then the only real conversation ever had
was when they traded me hmm I was there
it was oh six I resigned were in
practice I'm supposed to go in for the
two-minute drill and scar Nekia whose
best old line coach ever right thing
he's like he put somebody else in like
Russ hoax teen he put him in at center
said of me and I'm like aw it's not a
good side was my day to be center on
during the two-minute drill I'm like
that's not a good sign so after practice
we get there and I'm like man I can't
believe he pulled me out of that drill
like am I on thin ice already what's
going on and at the end of the meeting
he breaks down he goes up tuck and he
talked to you real quick I'm like yeah
coach he said so I I've been told that
during practice we we traded you to
Cleveland now Adam I'd already been cut
three or four times in my career so I I
was like happy that I got traded traded
like sounded cool yeah it was like
traded I said for what
values I was like for what yeah and he
said I don't know probably a bag of
balls with scar nakiya's response and
what's funny about it is I had told my
age I wanted to be traded to Cleveland
because I was battling for like the
eighth or ninth spot in New England and
the Charles Bentley tore his knee for
the Browns first day I'm signing after
the Saints so I went to Cleveland they
traded a conditional seventh round pick
from me which is what only the elite
players get traded for anytime a guy
gets traded for yourself I welcome to
the club but that's like my thing and
welcome to the club
the exclusive club so the next day or
that night I fly to clean I go in the
cold tub and like Larry is o sees me the
cold up he's like we're gonna do piss in
the cold tub I'm like now I'm just
getting my legs right for when I go
there and and Brady's in the cold tub to
reading like the front page of the
newspaper like Brady's gone person I
ever met that doesn't just read a sports
section
yeah on NFL team he's reading like
something and he said and people like
wait what he's like I said yeah I just
got traded to Cleveland and I remember
Brady's reaction we're just kind of like
oh man like that's always say he kind of
like looked up his like mom and like and
I don't know if he meant like oh man you
gotta go to Cleveland or oh man like NFL
it's just crazy that like you could have
just been out at practice yeah and now
you're in the cold tub and you're traded
to Cleveland
so I fly to Cleveland and I'm starting
for them right away next preseason game
like that quickly because of injuries
and you'll you'll appreciate this too I
get to Cleveland okay and you know love
Charles Bentley going down was a big
deal they signed him to a massive huge
huge so I get there by far the most
reporters I've ever had around me after
a practice you know it's middle of
training getting nothing else to talk
about who are the story of the moment
that day everybody the story that day
you are the whoa
offseason yet right so so I have like 12
cameras eight you know all kind of
people around me and they're asking me
questions Ross Tucker's veteran
experience will help Browns oline adjust
to winning ways and what's funny about
it is they're asking me like you know
you came from New England like what
what's your perception of the Browns and
I always tell this story I said
well you know I hear great things about
Romeo Crennel everybody New England
raves about him so I'm happy to be here
with him
we've got some unbelievable young talent
with Braylon Edwards and Kellen Winslow
Charlie fries and up-and-coming young
quarterback you know it's it's a really
exciting time to be at Brown I always
tell the story because I say like if I
could have told the truth right
my exact response would have been Romeo
Crennel is way too nice of a head coach
that's not gonna work
Maurice carthon has no idea what he's
doing as an offensive coordinator Kellen
Winslow and Braylon Edwards are punks
who went offsides four times in practice
today that's not gonna work
I don't think Charlie Frey has a prayer
in hell of being good but you know what
they're gonna pay me football they're
gonna pay me money to play football and
Cleveland this year so I'm happy to be
here
I like that what it leaders how awesome
would it be if you could just tell the
truth that literally would have been
what I said I would be like this team's
gonna stink but they're gonna pay me
money to play football in Cleveland Ohio
this year so I'm thrilled to be here I'm
happy beer thank you for asking me I
would love it that's why when we see a
Jalen Ramsey or a Martellus Bennett or
even Baker less last time when he made
the Duke Johnson comments a lot of the
NFL established former players are like
that's not gonna fly you never talk
about another man's money yeah I at the
time just went
[ __ ] man Baker really is out here living
like a cowboy and speaking that truth
yeah I know that's not gonna last
forever but there's a reason why I love
doing video segments whatever with the
young guys before they're in the NFL
it's not beaten out of them yet yes
they're still they still think that they
can make that comment before the Georgia
South Carolina game yeah get to fight
the fans route up and they get tweets
and they get that dopamine that feels
good after a while in the NFL it just it
gets sucked out of you it does
well you just learn and then the game
ends and then they want to join the
media and they need to bring it back all
of a sudden right they can't the the 110
percent doesn't work anymore right you
can't do that anymore no and but I it's
funny because where I sit with all the
different podcasts and the radio show
and stuff
I like when guys like Jalen Ramsey and
Baker Mayfield say stuff like that it
it's great topics yes but even like the
stuff Jalen did recently with they're
gonna have to pay me in on godly amount
they're not getting a discount that just
doesn't help you know I mean you got
suspended last year and by the way you
got 2/5 your option in 2020 so they
might not have it to pay you next year
like why do you think it's a gift er
that right why do you think it is that
they didn't pay you yet because you
pretty you you put videos like that
yeah it's just not smart it's tough
because I'm always at this crossroads
I want individuality I like [ __ ] talkers
I love right people speaking their truth
at the same time business-wise it's
always smarter to shut the [ __ ] out yes
the only time it's worked as a Antonio
Brown it's the only time and I firmly
believed that blond mustache and the
mink coat and the hair and going all
these events it was to convince the
Steelers that he was not stable yet he
should be moved and to that I applaud
him so he was you believe it was really
all by design act that he's talking
about his mental stability at all I
think that the fact that the day he
signed with the Raiders the mustache
came off and he shaved most of his head
I went mmm that's really interesting it
was the day he got to Oakland I think
you might be right because my thing is
he's very eccentric but people that work
out three times a day like I also think
that he is you talk about someone whose
identity is wrapped up in their
athletics
I think Antonio Brown is obsessed with
that kind of stuff he he has changed so
much so I used to be the moderator of
all the panels at the rookie symposium
and he was so different that I even
remember his first couple years in the
league he had come up to me on the field
before the game like hey what's up man
like just like a normal like good and
then a couple years ago like I had to
interview him on the sidelines like
after a West one game and it was like it
was like the Tom Cruise thing standing
on the couch for Matt Lauer like it was
like wow he's totally changed yeah but
at the same point I think the thing that
I try and remember is a lot of these
guys enter the league
21 22 years old and then they become
stars at like 27 and then they become
really stars like 28 29 and then when
there were 30 their careers over so for
me I think about how different I was at
22 to I was 27 and I think about how I
wore suits all the diamond Hastings
Nebraska and I really didn't have that
many opinions and I wasn't even
confident in my own opinions and then I
thought about when I was like got to New
York at like 27 that's why I give these
guys so much of a pass because the
perfect it's it to me it's more normal
to be an O'Dell to be a very rich 25
year old that wants to go to Monaco than
it is to be a JJ Watt who'd rather have
a cabin in the woods and improve every
day like that's why we marvel over those
people with work ethic so I get more I
think the people that are the Tom
Brady's that JJ Watts like the perfect
people they're more weird to me than
people with flaws because every day I
see people with flaws well I tell people
all the time there's no handbook for
being young famous and rich NFL does so
many things to try to help these guys
but even like even like my buddies okay
high school and college that are well
educated they're like man how are those
guys like that you know I know for a
fact I've seen my one buddy at Atlantic
City try to double down on 37 cents all
he had left was 37 cents he told the
blackjack dealer he want him to double
that home like he he also told the
blackjack dealer that his grill was
worth more than the blackjack dealers
life like I've seen my buddies right in
their 20s when they were not rich yeah
and they were not famous right like I'm
just telling you if you took all my high
school and college buddies thing gave
them and gave 1 million bucks and some
of them would have done some real bad
things real dumb things it's easy when
you've never been in that situation yeah
just say so how do these guys do this if
I would never do that why would you at
20 million dollars and you're gonna go
out there and get a Bentley don't you
understand that as soon as you drive it
off the lot it depreciates in value and
I want to be like first if you've never
been able to afford a Bentley you're not
allowed to weigh in on
because the true thing is these kids
grew up and went I'm gonna be a star
what do you want to put it into a
[ __ ] IRA you went on to get like a
five to nine and worried about his
child's education like they're not
living the same life as you they're
living so that you can do that [ __ ]
they're gonna do the crazy [ __ ] like ah
that's my fear is that we're gonna lose
that because we've yelled at it so much
and we've degraded it so much because of
course it's smarter to save your money
of course it is but I like that some
people are not doesn't have to be me but
I'm not gonna badmouth them for it what
did they ask me my advice I would say I
wouldn't do that the funny thing about
that is but I'm glad that they did the
NFL has all these programs like I
remember one time the Patriots they had
like a session on estate planning yeah
oh and I went in the room and there was
probably like eight guys there Adam it
was literally the starting five
offensive linemen and the 3/4 bath yeah
and and maybe the kicker okay so that's
number one but number two it was
literally the eight or nine people that
needed it the least you know what I mean
like the airline people that they're
gonna get somebody to help them with
that stuff banner in the future they the
guys the irony of it is the guys that
really need the guidance don't go for
the guys it's the guys that don't need
it
yeah that think I'm gonna get it anyway
I'm gonna get the guy into anyway we we
just assume that people with money have
smart people around them taking care and
the true thing is is a lot of people
with money especially if they've come
from bad situations have people around
them that they trust but they don't
necessarily should trust them you know
right I remember asking Travis Henry in
the cult up I was like by the way when
you mentioned his name but he had like
eight kids so like Travis Henry was
walking one of those guys I grew up on I
was like this guy's living the life
right now he I think like you probably
get to it well you probably get to a
certain point when you have like four or
five you're like I'm just going all-in
he's like I'm going for the record so he
the funny thing is Mike pasillo an
offensive lineman with the bills when I
was there he bought Travis's like UConn
okay
like after a year for like 15
like Travis was not good with money and
not really a shocker and he sold his
Yukon so then after we found out all the
kids that Travis had we used to bust
Priscilla's chops about how many of them
yeah you know or conceived conceived in
the Yukon and then I saw him one time in
the cold tub and I said I said Travis
what are you doing like investment-wise
he said what are you talking about tuck
like stocks and bonds I said yeah he's
like don't know nothing about it don't
know nothing about it
and I think a lot of the guys are like
that and I would I and I actually would
say this to those guys if you don't then
don't do anything with it yet yes just
have it in the bank and don't just give
it to somebody that you don't know if
they know what they're doing
I actually got my series seven and
sixty-six securities licenses while I
was playing because I thought all the
guys like on a 401k day would come and
they'd hand me their formula tuck fill
this out for me tuck fill this out for
me anyway so I thought I'm gonna be able
to start financial advising while I'm a
player and then I had a back surgery and
then Buffalo cut me and it ruined my
whole plan but I was gonna be able to
like start my next career because all
those guys you were gonna be Andy
Dufresne doing all of the guards yes and
an inmate's taxes a while being a
president yeah all those guys really
wanted it all they really wanted
somebody that they trust yeah that's
like they stay new I was willing to
punch them in the head for them like and
they knew I was quote unquote smart so
they it would have worked I mean it
would have been really good but then I
got cutting and when you're like then
you go to a new team you don't have the
trust you have those guys to say hey
here's my money I'm gonna take what you
just said I'm gonna turn this to the 33%
really quick I in the last few weeks
have met with a financial adviser
because like what you were saying it's
not just football players I think young
people are intimidated by finances and
money yeah and they hear about you got
to get in real estate you got to get in
the stock market I'm just telling you
guys go to a place that's around you a
fidelity something like that and they'll
give you like a free consultation and
they'll just show you where you are so
if I can tear this link to actionable
stuff like non ya know players like if
you feel as though you're behind realize
that it's all [ __ ] okay
just go and ask somebody yeah that's the
advice I'm gonna give ya and and if you
want ask multiple people yes
oh don't not a little one / and make
sure you see what the fees are in the
hidden fees and then go with the person
that you like that felt useful that was
awesome alright good that was good
advice did you enjoy this oh I could
literally do an hour and a half but I've
realized that we've already done like an
hour and twenty five it's unbelievable
so we could do like another four hours
alright cuz I know I haven't touched on
everything cuz you get the two hundred
thousand hello
how long are your podcast I didn't even
realize it or it doesn't matter it's the
Internet
nothing matters it's awesome alright
Ross Tucker NFL on Twitter and let's
build the Instagram what are you on
Instagram at Ross Tucker NFL at Ross
though on both oh yeah I got the same
vitam Instagram people alright you I
suppose they every game I go to I post a
video of the pressbox food people love
it i people love suppressed by happen
here Ross is obsessed with pressbox
foods fest we just didn't get to it
today you'll have to come back again
alright check out your podcast just type
in Ross Tucker your football podcast and
there's a bunch you too Ross Tucker calm
you can see how you like gambling you
like fantasy I got it it has a podcast
with Evan Silva so you know it's good
yes fantasy fees yes all right Ross
you're the man Thank You H yeah homies
holla holla holla we'll talk to you
later 33 % you are the [ __ ]
I'll see you soon
[Music]